the kind of thunder saying hey no well I
know but he says nothing nothing coming
with you
a little nubbins me he said it's nice to
see me this it's not wrong thanks for
translating well you were not a
microphone don't you hear you if you're
not a microphone a living voice not what
I'm doing
very happy it's my daughter Sophie is it
you know I'm lying like all men do
that's true we do please could you tell
her not to believe man you really told
her that don't believe me because even
though it's politically correct times
that guys are predators I have no idea
what he just said What did he say
did you sell Sophie yeah don't believe
men because they're all predators cuz I
told her that myself I'm not a predator
I wouldn't want an order oh come on I'm
not Jewish you want to be could Evie
actually we're not allowed to do that
because we don't have missionaries no no
no you're not allowed to tell anybody
that their religion is wrong because it
doesn't matter right no I'm not Jewish
Jean okay hey do you uh are you
surprised all this stuff that's going on
cuz knowing the way men act no I mean it
used to be called the casting couch and
you remember the old jokes about the
caveman with the clubs hitting the gun
then drag him into the cave
unfortunately it's not news at all I
mean the only thing that's happened is
women have finally stood up arch their
backs and said enough is enough and
we're not gonna take it and rightfully
so I think the bad guys should be put
away and become somebody's girlfriend in
a dark room by the way for those of you
that like that sort of thing
god bless ya see Jim it's not a problem
no everything's problems I don't want to
know forced on me by a larger man
smaller would be okay absolutely if you
had on dragon boots you better take it
are there any stories from your pant cut
you know we live in in debt now is a
different time than before are there any
stories from your past by the way you're
never gonna mention my new book I
mentioned it before you came in okay
Simmons on power it's it's a it's called
my journey through the corridors of
power and your guy that's made a
shitload of money and you have a lot of
power more to come yeah and uh
movie that Johnny Depp did more to come
did he Mordecai Mordecai adult version
bad movie why was it bad but he's a good
guy he's great guy yeah I can't tell you
what the story is more hey who wants to
copyright on this bag with the money
trademark is the correct or not right I
don't know that's all I do
I own my own the money bag logo and have
for 28 years
Congrats the people give you your people
do does it bother you people give you
[ __ ] about these things that you try to
do like the devil horns or you don't
care if they're upset by it I'm thrilled
that anybody gives me the time of day
much less anything else there's a very
sad kind of thing and I confronted
confronted confronted oh my god that's
ok constructive I'd be nervous if I were
with us - did you guess I don't know
where that what the hell is that
confronted I didn't mean to say that ok
don't worry about it confronted some of
the ladies who have done interviews with
me
Jota was terrific you know and Kathie
Lee and stuff and they're reading the
book and they're saying what do you mean
we can't do it all of course you can
women can do everything my mother did my
mother raised me as a single mother but
why would any woman recommend to a 20
year old female to have a child and go
for a career at the same time when the
smart thing would be and this is my
opinion and I'm not a woman is have a
child later don't depend on men they're
gonna cheat on you and they're gonna lie
to you
we're [ __ ] not mean ok but we're
talking about straight men statistically
you're gay man you're even more
promiscuous oh my god yes no I'm being
serious for a second Rock another
seconds over let's get busy stupid no if
you're if you're and what I talk about
in the book is there's every reason in
the world why you can and should access
power and money you can have the right
thing at the right place and the right
time for instance a few gym we're doing
this on top of a hill and you know where
they had claude claude king singing on
Wolverton mountain there's only a
thousand people in town
wouldn't make the shitload of money that
you make right here you've got to have
the right thing right would you do the
gift of gab and so on you're in New York
City a lot of people the right co-host
not so much but respectfully and this is
something women don't get enough
attention I don't mean the stuff on the
street and everything else but financial
advice and business advice and so on so
I I have a daughter
Sophie's 25 thank God she didn't have a
child at 20 not because you're not
allowed to but because the choices are
not as smart to get to become a driver
you need to get a driver's license and
before that you have to go to school
driving school how to do it and so on so
you're qualified to drive a car to have
a child
there's no qualification you just have a
child and good luck you don't know what
colic is you don't know when to feed the
baby so I'm here to say that if you want
to access power and if you want to
compete with men toe-to-toe because they
don't give a [ __ ] you're there well
they're gonna compete with you the way
they compete with men because they want
money and power that's the nature of
life there are no girls basketball rules
and business guys will compete with you
against you the way they do with your
co-host that's right so you say let me
ask you would you say like did they
misinterpret your comments and make it
look like Jesus you can't have career
and be a woman and have a kid at 20 you
can't just stand by every word I'm
saying that's my opinion
you want to jump off a building god
bless you but I'm here to tell you it's
not gonna be good for you my mother is
the example beef my mother never got
business advice or anything like that
she was not well educated and stuff so
my mother worked at a sweat factory and
raised an only child yours truly by
herself I don't want to see young women
go through that where was the father
well shamefully like many fathers and
many families around the world men
abandoned their families Maya my father
abandoned us see I don't even say me
when I was six and seven years old I'm
not gonna do that to my family so a
piece of advice heartfelt to all young
ladies out there do not
have children when you're 20 you're not
qualified you're not a mature woman
anymore you don't have the money or the
power and you don't have enough of a
career going on because you haven't put
in the time and the guy that you think
you're gonna marry that's gonna be your
boyfriend with you forever the wake-up
call is he's gonna he's an [ __ ] he's
gonna cheat on you
and you're gonna leave him and then
you're back to square one and as soon as
you have that child especially teenage
mothers game over do you worry at all
like with all the scandals coming out
that there are things from your past now
that could come back and in the context
of right now not look very good for you
my problem is farm animals I've done
something you've had sex with farm
animals no no I've grilled them I don't
know what you're talking about I was
just asking I have I eat them I swallow
and stuff no how did you handle down the
road when you did have a girlfriend and
you weren't married and you were doing
what you were doing because all right
once in a while there are the crazy ones
who are like now I want this and now I
want that or they're threatening to
expose you even though you're like
pretty open about it exposed what well
that is that you hooked up with them or
whatever
well so what okay you cared you don't
take you acting inappropriately if
anything my mother used to bitch-slap me
all the time treat you no remember
you've got a mom and so on treat women
well I mean I think I would hope I've
treated women well respectfully and so
on and thank you and yeah and you were
open and honest about what the sexual
are if anything I'd rather people not
know as much as they know but my life's
been an open book but women were knew
what they were in the book is called on
power yes see what I did there one one
of the few books that I've written but
you held it up backward and he doesn't
alive a year oh [ __ ] that's a good thing
you're good-looking cuz yeah he's not
bright but it's the most popular in jail
I have a feeling a compliment I take it
as such do you mind being the one on the
bottom or the tongue well not if I'm
popular see that yeah doesn't matter
because you know why jeez first because
that will be my power when I'm in jail
right everybody's gonna want me a piece
of this I threw up a little bit my mouth
that's okay of course I'd rather that's
not vomit I'd rather throw up in your
mouth a little bit
yeah you know what I probably allowed
him a big kiss
are you guys on the road at all are you
still doing your Sullivan
oh my god doing the solo band kisses
running all over the place I brought out
as you may know the largest box it
evolved yeah and a few weeks ago you
sell any most all sold out we start
delivering them I'm gonna go around the
world deliver gene Simmons vault dot-com
kids it's the only place to get it
there's no retail right means stores
January I start going around the world
and delivering them we have on power or
my new book from Harper Collins yeah
what is let me start you and what is
something cuz you know you talk about
like you've done these things and you
take a shot you you are you tried to get
a trademark on this or on that what is
something that somebody has offered you
to do for money and then you're like now
it's just not worth excitin what they
want me to do just crack kiss crack
you wouldn't do you wouldn't sell I
don't believe that but I don't do it you
think you would no I don't see any
reason why you can't and shouldn't see
what I'm doing double negatives there I
know you remember from your funk and
Wagnalls
that double negatives mean the opposite
that's right try everything it's okay to
fail I fail every day in my previous
book me ink failure means nothing you
remember when you first you're straight
right you remember will notice B yeah
when you first went out with the first
girl you ever tried did you succeed no
I've had I've had many failures with of
course so you try you drink you dust
yourself you know off the ground you try
again check it out married now what that
means alright and by the way I'm
assuming at one point Norton Norton I'm
a shoe assuming assuming my tongs too
big that's okay so I like it is okay got
a funder make you very happy I would
show you how big it is but my tongue
that is but yes the floors a little bit
dirty are you flirting no we're just
talking about in fact I just I just
spent a lot of money on a kiss
blacklight poster off eBay
but I had framed in museum glass from
the okona
can't get any money from that no you're
not doing a joke he's serious it's a
real kiss product see the spittle on the
corner yeah service no no I'm happy to
say that yes sir he's never just happy I
bought it
happy what was the question you're
asking I don't remember how does Jim
harness his power after he was I know I
was asking you about I don't remember I
was asking about the band being on tour
and you see what I'm doing is we have
the largest box set of all time gene
Simmons voltcom I have the gene Simmons
banner hanging around we have a new book
called on power I'm starting a family
office in New York called motion wealth
management with some oppenheimer guys
you should look up what family office
means we have a Simmons book imprint
that's launching right now in a few
weeks you're gonna be hearing about I'm
announcing January the 6th and Los
Angeles
gene Simmons money back colas which are
already in thousand stores and sodas
excuse me met money back colas as in
soda cream sodas diet sodas and all that
stuff main with cane sugar you'll hear
more about it shortly I said by the way
I see the kid rock and brews with the
the you and Paula restaurant I see it in
every every airport on it is it is huge
we are LAX and we're opening 15 just in
the Chicago area
Atlanta Airport is opening now it's
enormous
so you're winding down a little bit
actually
let's get serious just for a second
you're right okay seconds over now let's
go back to running
if you're running a race what do you do
when you get close to the finish line do
you slow down heck no you speed up speed
up so right so I'm sixth I use AT&T
I like it when the host picks on the
coast very I'm very team Sam but I'm
more team Jean team Jim James so so I'm
68
I'm closer to the end and I was in the
beginning get up off your lazy ass and
do stuff so that's what the books about
right it's never too late how proud is
that
mother who's standing in line with all
those other piss faced little 18 year
olds who have no clue what a diploma
means and she's proudly standing in line
getting that diploma at 90 because it's
never too late right
but it's also much later than you think
yeah and you can also self educate
yourself because anything you wanna know
is right there in the palm of your hands
you you said by the way you're getting
towards the end do you worry about that
at all well there's nothing you can do
about it no I know but usually what do
you think the only that wants to die I
mean especially if you have a good life
and I live in America and God bless and
that's an appropriate thing I mean god
blesses in Bob way probably not a good
phrase but god bless america
sounds right but do you start to panic
him like like wow man this is this is
gonna move on without me how do you feel
about it you carry everyday above ground
as my dear mother continues to say is a
great opportunity so if you only have 24
hours of life that God or somebody gave
you what are you gonna do watch I Love
Lucy reruns or you're gonna get up off
your lazy ass and do something do you
think a wealth create jobs given to
philanthropy but right there in the palm
of your hand is everything you ever
wanted to know as an example Siri what
do you call me you're asking me who is
Jim Norton you'll need to unlock your
iPhone first I'm surprised you have no
problem telling me to Laurie's every
dude by the way I love that on the back
of the phone what is that little kiss
rock and roll over thing to thine own
self be true right if you have a brand
put it on your goddamn so I like it now
whatever URL well that's not the point
you have John Norton com yes I do why
wouldn't it be on your phone it's not
it's not it's not as marketable as the
cover of rock and roll over that's just
not but everybody's got a brand and your
reputation precedes you and why not get
a free advertisements okay right now
you're wearing some obscure band
your t-shirt yeah Black Sabbath that's
great but I'm wearing Sophie Simmons on
my t-shirt so use every opportunity to
rip your loins that's right right thank
you for that of course but I'm saying is
that rock and roll a sticker what is
that on the back your phone just like it
you can get anything as you know we make
kiss condoms kiss caskets we'll get you
coming we'll get your goal I don't need
condoms I don't wear that I wouldn't
care who's on a condom I'm not putting
refuses with you with anything with
anyone
yeah I mean I don't mind them but he was
nice to see a rabbi doing the
engineering there I like no rabbi no his
mother his mother left him for family
for our mother his mother left him for a
Jewish man and never came back
yeah and also you don't want yeah what's
your mom's name Kim you might not hear
I'm sorry Kim you have to clear head
phone I remember heard that she was back
week on the Travis dog yeah what does
that mean Travis dog is his nickname Eli
so I was like Travis Bickle you're
looking at me no no yeah not Travis dog
and he just gave me so wieck's it's cool
what can people do to harness their
power Gigi what you really can do some
ice to teach sixth grade in Spanish
Harlem English is not my first language
it's my fourth I wasn't born in America
so everything every place I got to and
everything I do
McLaren the high-end luxury car company
just hired me as their brand Meister I
did brand work for Oh everybody Kodak
and IndyCar and all that stuff we have
one minute changes so you know we have
to end the show everything I know I
taught myself and all the knowledge of
mankind is on the palm of your hands
please read on power you don't have to
get it I'm a rich son of a [ __ ] but I'm
here to tell you that you too can have
much more power especially you ladies
out there you deserve it you need to get
it and you need to stop depending on men
I know it's insulting and all that but
get over it you should be ruling
countries yes you women out there
there's no reason why you shouldn't and
why you can't
and the only thing holding you back is
yourself educate yourself have the right
thing at the right place and the right
time it's not gonna be easy you're gonna
fail many times get over it
pick yourself up when I was a little kid
I tried to walk the first time a baby
and I fell on my face I tried it again
eventually I walked and so did everybody
we all fail so get over the failure
stuff and you're in New York City you
have lots of opportunities you're in
Davenport Iowa and you want to get into
finance and stuff come to New York don't
don't be don't stay in Davenport
well there are great places yippeee
slanty Michigan and Davenport but not
for politics nationwide politics go to
the right place if you want the right
thing if you want to be a country singer
don't live in Paris but don't know